[Music]
get ready for the cutest thing you'll
see all day
that little cutie right there is bianca
the three-year-old daughter of Vanessa
Bryant and her late husband Kobe Bryant
making a surprise cameo in her oldest
sister Natalia's tick tock video
[Music]
like I said cutest thing you'll see all
day let's break it all down in the sweet
clip the seventeen-year-old is Dancing
with our cousins - we rock from the 2008
flick camp rock the girls are totally
slaying the routine until Bianca slides
into the frame all smiles rocking a
Laker shirt and straight-up steals the
show
[Music]
Vanessa shared the clip on Instagram
alongside the caption quote little
sister Bianca Bella Bibi kiddo all that
cuteness comes just days after the WNBA
honored Vanessa and Kobe's late daughter
Gianna by selecting her as an honorary
draft pick Gianna and Kobe both died in
January in a helicopter crash along with
seven others two of the other victims
Alisa Altobelli and Payton Chester were
also selected as honorary draft picks it
would have been a dream come true for
her she worked tirelessly every single
day she wanted to be one of the greatest
athletes of all time just like her daddy
[Music]
so thank you thank you for honoring my
little girl
[Music]
Koby and GG loved the WNBA this is a
sweatshirt
[Music]
thank you I want to congratulate all of
these tears drop pics
[Music]
so congratulations work hard never
settle
[Music]
who's that mom hood mentality as for
vanessa ET recently caught up with her
friend
Lala Anthony who told us how the mom of
three is doing I talk to her every
single day and just you know continue to
pray for her and stay positive for her
she I tell her every day she's the
strongest woman I know and I'm really
really proud of just how she's handling
everything and just want to continue to
be there you know as much as I can for
her as a friend she's just an amazing
and amazing human being just just
amazing it was nice to see her on TV
with Natalia the other day I mean how
how are they doing yeah you know I mean
doing as expected you know in what what
happened obviously but it's our job as
friends and family to just continue to
uplift them and pray for them and
definitely let everybody out there know
to do the same they they feel it they
receive it and they're very appreciative
of it